this video was made possible by honker
impact third the hand of God rumble in
the jungle the 2008 Wimbledon final when
we talk about some of the most iconic
sporting moments ever these are some of
the classics that have stood the test of
time if you're a basic ass normy sports
fan nah we aren't here to talk about
this boring overhyped pansy-ass
[ __ ] we're talking about the good stuff
I'm talking Saiyans rematch at OA fo vs.
endo Oh
talking gate of [ __ ] booty Lord
[ __ ] real sports at anime sports
sports anime used to be the
underachieving child of the medium
sitting in this weird limbo gray area
where it didn't fully appeal to either
of the target demographics it was meant
to weebs wouldn't want to watch it
because it was about jock ridden bro
sports and sports fans wouldn't want to
watch it because it was bad as weird as
Chinese we've [ __ ]
luckily in recent times the reputation
of watching sports anime has become more
widely accepted with a handful of recent
titles even becoming breakout hits so
today I wanted to show my appreciation
for sports anime by talking about all
the weird and wonderful things about
them because I like sports anime I've
always loved sports anime I mean it's
just really an excuse to show tornament
art after tournament our cough the
Toyman ark after why would I not love a
John Rowe that is made up of 90%
tornament dark sea one of the appeals of
sports anime is that you're taking
something based on reality we're
transporting it to the anime world with
anime rules and nowhere is this more
apparent than with superpowers by
superpowers I don't mean athletes flying
about Dragon Ball Z style flying over
some sports pool of some kind cuz I'll
be [ __ ] stupid and ridiculously
over-the-top and that's why it only
happens occasionally know what I'm
talking about how anime can take the
simplest move and turn it into a goddamn
superpower specialized techniques
different formations personalized skills
if there's one rule to adhere to it's
that every move needs a name no matter
how big or impressive or no one will
give a [ __ ] something like this may look
impressive to a football fan but if you
know nothing about football how are you
supposed to know how amazing this is if
it's not called something like
[Music]
because it's based on reality you can
literally [ __ ] any skill into an
epic superpower like imagine how stupid
akashi's Emperor I would look in real
life
cleanest people just literally kneeling
down to the most basic of crossovers you
can do [ __ ] but that's part of the charm
of it because what sounds cooler to you
a sudden change in poor direction
causing people to wrong-foot themselves
and fall over or a [ __ ] magic emperor
I that causes people to kneel before
them because his orders are absolute
this is still a show about basketball by
the way and this becomes truly apparent
when you learn about some kind of
specialized technique from an anime then
you see the real-life counterpart and
you realize it really wasn't as cool as
the anime made it out to be let's take
one of the most iconic moves in all of a
sports anime the Dempsey roll that's
right if those ultimate finisher nobody
stands a chance once it gets going
because you're about to be hit by
multiple 10-ton punches from each
direction there is no move cooler than
this and when you look around a better
ring now what that's it
what do you mean this is the Dempsey
roll where's the steam where's the
[ __ ] jet engines didn't even shout
out the bloody move name this isn't
realistic at all next you'll be telling
me they're strapping metallic mechanised
arms and boxers would be a slight health
and safety issue but aside from giving
super mega awesome move names for the
most mundane of actions how else can we
portray the power of a move so the
audience can fully comprehend where the
players are feeling like in the moment
well we get to the visual metaphors move
names are one thing but if you truly
want the audience to grasp boy is like
to be a player on the field it's all
about the visual metaphors some may be
simple like haikyuu using the crow
imagery when someone jumps ping pong the
animation proven that you can awareness
you have a power of gods and anime by
your side with a dash of LSD and then
you have ICO 21 giving a different
over-the-top visual cue for everybody
move for
one person this guy isn't just running
fast he's running faster than the speed
of light which shouldn't be possible
according to Einstein
when Einstein can go [ __ ] himself and I
get it sometimes we need an artistic
rendition to properly portray and
exaggerate and move while actions so the
audience can anchor it to a feeling like
we all know the teleports behind you
meme that we see all over anime or what
no one seems to mention is that by far
the worst offender of doing this an
ironic Lee is every [ __ ] ball in the
history of anime sports nothing personal
kidding all of this however is
completely irrelevant next to the magnum
opus of any technique in sports anime
the teske sewed from Prince of tennis
you see by alternating the spin on a
tennis ball what this does is tesca can
kind of manipulate the direction the
ball comes back in sort of makes sense
right I mean you can kind of see some
real-world logic here so with this basic
principle in mind what tesca can do and
his single stroke is the spin he puts on
the board translates this into a
gravitational force which starts sucking
in planets now this gravitational force
becomes so powerful that he can create a
black hole which starts sucking in the
entire universe which tesco can now use
to recreate the Big Bang and I know what
you're thinking what's this got to do of
tennis anymore
well if you pay attention [ __ ]
and knew anything about physics you'd
know that this tennis big bank released
thousands of planets size tennis balls
which spread all over the entire
universe and and that's not all
[ __ ] because this is war killed
off the dinosaurs ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
that's the tezuka's own it makes perfect
sense but because of ridiculous moments
like these I want to take a quick moment
to show appreciation for how amazing
sports anime can look when it just looks
realistic
whether it be free making the act of
swimming look more refreshing than a
cold drink in the Sahara Desert
Hani Bardot's crisp and intense
choreography that feels as exhausting is
actually playing it or some of the
performances in URI are nice I remember
getting proper chills the first time I
saw the year
nice choreography just because of how
damn beautiful and graceful eloped
you know before before the rest of the
series happens
it proves that sometimes the most
impressive thing you can do with the
sports anime is just to make it look and
feel like the actual sport because there
are also other things that acts a bit
weird in the genre but before that I
wanted to introduce the sponsor for
today's video Hong Kong impact Thirds
now this is the second time Hong Kong
impact have come to me and I'm honestly
really happy to promote it again as you
can see here as an action combat game
that is free-to-play and runs on your
mobile and honestly still surprises me
how good this game looks for a free
mobile game the real-time combat system
is really satisfying and has more depth
and it initially seems especially when
you start unlocking different characters
weapons and skins because in this game
the skins aren't just cosmetic where
they affect your abilities and play
style if you want to know Mei is my
favorite girl cuz I like the close
quarters rapid attack style and either
way Mei is BAE alright the game has
since been updated since my last shout
out with a new skin and character being
added just a few weeks ago which you can
now get your hands on and also the
latest story chapter has just been added
for you to play through and follow along
with yes that's right there is a story
mode that come to the game complete with
cutscenes and it sounds like your cup
tea or you just want to try this out
then there is a link in the description
below where you can download it on
either iOS or Android and with that we
can get back to our sports anime as we
are just talking about anime Sports
superpowers and visual metaphors but
here's the thing everything I've just
described can be applied to any
real-life activity whether it
technically counts as a sport or not and
because of this there are a whole myriad
of shows that might not technically be a
sports but they certainly feel like a
sports anime they're not Sports anime
they're sports and in May what I'm
talking about here is the Chi hiya
Furies ik Argy initial DS and even the
food Wars of the world shows which take
the traditional sports anime formula and
applies it to an activity or a game the
dictionary definition of sport is an
activity involving physical exertion and
skill in which an individual or team
competes against each other or others
for entertainment which could apply to
pretty much anything he'll this is anime
so you can take any activity put it in a
competitive environment add the actual
girls orgasm in doing so
activity and you have yourself ahead
show shokugeki and kakigori are pretty
much turns cooking and gambling at in
extreme sport at this point so why else
can we do
extreme mining Edward cider hands
loading pornhub while your phone's at 1%
battery well you know what I guess by
that same definition doesn't that mean
you go also counts as a sports anime
here you can take this kind of worms I
just opened I don't want to deal with
this right now take it take you [ __ ]
take it I don't I don't want it when I
side know about things that are
debatably sport or not I am still
waiting for an eSports anime I know a
lot you're gonna shout kings avatar but
that didn't really turn out to be an
eSports anime but more an anime with
eSports in it so I'm looking at you
riots games yes you right he just used a
no game no life OST for their newest
trailer look I know you want to make one
just just just do it already just just
do it make the first eSports anime look
you can even script ESM to win something
as low it'll be perfect that way you all
count as a fantasy anime too then you
have the sports anime with completely
made-up sports that we wish really
existed Air Gear did something near
impossible and almost made the gaps of
rollerblading cool again Keijo is a bot
wrestling sport which technically
doesn't exist but it does in my heart
and that's all that matters okay and
finally we have girls and Panzer
portraying the fictional sport of tanker
II where a bunch of cute anime girls
basically play World of Tanks with real
tanks and live ammunition now you may be
wondering how can this possibly count as
a sport because that just sounds
ridiculously stupid and dangerous to
keep on this train of things which
follow the Sports anime formula let's
talk about the setups it's no secret
that many sports anime follow a similar
set up and part of the reason I love
sports anime is that in a lot of ways
it's the purest form of Shonen and it's
so unapologetic about it most of them
tackle themes of rivalry determination
hard work camaraderie it's about power
scaling power ceiling power rankings
it's constantly about training and
progression and while predictable it's
always interesting to see how different
series talk with these in their own way
if you're just looking for a cheap and
cheerful shown in fix there is no better
way than sports anime however with us
said you can't deny that there are many
things about the setting that have got a
little cliche I think most of this boils
down to so many shows taking place in
the high school setting with lots of the
same character archetypes though you'd
be forgiven for
these characters are in high school
because half of all sports characters
don't even look they're [ __ ] aged a
lot of characters already look really
old for their age like almost everyone
in croco bud croco looks like fully
grown men wearing school uniforms all
over the whole power escalation
progression trying to make new arrivals
look more intimidating than the last
your honor with some characters just
taking the [ __ ] piss like if this is
our athletes look in high school is what
the [ __ ] pros of the world look like
honestly I would love to see more sports
anime that is not set in high school
where the ultimate goal is to jerk off
your teammates hard enough to find a way
to Nationals
of course the protagonist is gonna be a
first-year who is either an absolute
genius or complete newbie and of course
we've got to win because this is the
last time we're gonna be able to play
with our sand pies guys our sand pies we
don't want to be like that other team of
[ __ ] who are crying because I don't
get to play with us damn it man I'm
taking the face when it gets me every
bloody time and then there is the
reminder that we are still indeed in
high school because there is nothing
more giant when the show finishes our
super intense what feels like life with
death match and then in the next episode
everyone's like oh [ __ ] guys your
[ __ ] homework to do like seriously
who the [ __ ] actually likes the homework
episodes like at least in the hot
springs of beach episode we get some
good fanservice to keep us distracted
but who the [ __ ] thought it would be a
good episode idea to see boys panic
studying to get moderately possible
grades and then what's supposed to
happen after Nationals is over
deuce implies graduate and realize that
dribbling a ball that Mac three is not
an employable skill sets does illuminae
go on a date gets offered a cheeky
[ __ ] then smack his date in the face
because he needs to remind that [ __ ]
the only one who can beat me is me this
is why I can appreciate when an anime
goes beyond high school and mirrors the
structure of the real international
stage and part of the draw when I first
saw a Poe and Yuri on ice was exactly
that the stage felt much grander the
stakes felt higher and I don't know
sometimes watching epode matches
actually feels like you're watching a
real sporting event and it was much
easier to absorb myself into it but on
occasion you also get a sports anime
with a sport merely acts as a vehicle to
explore deeper themes I've talked to
lots about my love for ping pong the
animation and how it's a crushingly
realistic portrayal of aspirations in
life but even more recently with megalo
box which everyone thought was just
gonna be an unrelenting hype machine i
he became a succinct exploration of
dreams of sacrifice and ambitions with
Joe himself acting as a vehicle for the
different characters around him to
explore this while also being an
unrelenting hyper machine but to bring
this all back no matter how a Sports
anime sets a self up or how many cliches
it ends up using or how over-the-top it
goes there is one more thing that I've
noticed sports anime has done for me at
least in the time I've been watching it
let's be honest alright I'm sure a lot
of us don't give a [ __ ] about sports and
certainly we don't give a [ __ ] about
every sport we are the one confused
[ __ ] in every sports anime where the
show just pauses for five minutes to
blatantly spell out the rules just for
us like the beginning of every show is a
sports rendition of our slash explain
like I'm five and as much as I'm joking
about this I've learned the rules of
American football baseball and
volleyball from watching sports anime
alone but that's the thing thanks for
watching these shows I've learned a
deeper appreciation to many sports I
would never have given a second look
otherwise and seen moments like actual
ice skaters profess their love for URI
and ice shows how much care and passion
can go into these shows they can have a
real world effect on anyone watching it
because these are real-life activities
they are based on and sometimes just
sometimes it can do something truly
magical getting a weave interested into
sports if you want to know my favorites
in the genre for hype it's hard to beat
the king Hajime no Ippo for an unfilled
to take on life and ambition it's ping
pong the animation and four most
underrated I've got to go with one else
a different take on sports anime that
focuses on winning using wine games
deception and trickery and it's
basically what would happen if Death
Note [ __ ] a baseball show because if
you haven't figured it out by now Sports
anime aren't about the sports it's about
the stories and characters behind them
so whether you want an underdog Shonen
tale or a crushing reflection of real
life ambition realistic or ridiculous
uplifting or painfully relatable you'll
find it all here and if you still want
that hasn't dove headfirst into sports
anime yet then you need to change that
because the bottom line is you don't
need to give a [ __ ] about sports to give
a [ __ ] about sports anime
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much again to honk I
impact for sponsoring this video if any
of what I talked about today interested
you then you can download their game by
clicking on the link below and I've also
got a quick announcement so I'm trying
something new this Saturday and I'm
going to be live-streaming my
impressions of the new season of anime
basically what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go through the seasonal charts we're
gonna watch all the Peavey's I haven't
seen any of these myself so I don't know
what any of them look like and then
we're just gonna see what looks good
what doesn't look good what we're gonna
be watching this season and what we're
gonna be avoiding this is something I've
been wanting to do for a while so if you
want to join in I'm gonna be live
streaming on twitch.tv slash gig on this
Saturday at 4 p.m. British Standard Time
that's 11:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
if you want to join in on the fun well
you can also follow me in my Twitter in
case any updates happen sorry if that's
me early for any of you in America but
we're gonna be going for him for a few
hours so hopefully you can catch it if
you wake up in time anyway that's it for
me now though I've been gigging and I
will see you all next time